ROGER: It's a magic square.
A magic square is an array of
numbers which you put in
columns and rows.
So in this case, there are four
rows and four columns,
going up and down, and you
put a number in each.
And the idea is to make sure
that the sum of all these
numbers going down in each
column is the same.
And the sum of all numbers
in each row is the same.
And the diagonals.
And the other diagonals.
So I want to draw in a
particular way my favorite
magic square.
And there are bigger
magic squares.
There are different famous magic
squares, such as the one
in Durar's painting.
But this--
I want to draw, showing you how
it has extra special magic
properties.
BRADY: Extra-special
magic properties?
That's a big promise.
Are you going to be able
to live up to that?
ROGER: Well, you be
the judge of that.
So I'm going to draw a square.
Hopefully draw a square.
And put in four columns,
four rows.
And I'm going to write the
numbers in a particular way,
such as in a modern
calculator.
So I'm going to write this
as 2, like that.
And as 5--
oops, that's meant
to be square.
And then 18.
And I'll do 18 as two boxes.
And then 51.
And 82.
This is going to take
a time, Brady.
This is a magic square.
Let me show you why.
If I add up all these numbers in
each row, they come to the
same total.
If I add up all these numbers,
that row, that row, that row,
and that row, each one comes
to the same number.
Or this diagonal, or that
diagonal, they add up-- or
this little square in here, they
all add up to the same
number, which is 176.
I'm writing it in normal
curly numbers.
You'll see the reason
why in a minute.
This 28, plus 15, plus
52, plus 81, is 176.
They're all the same number.
That's what makes
a magic square.
If I do a diagonal, 58 plus
21, plus 15, plus
82 is equal to 176.
So this is quite remarkable,
that somebody could dream up
something--
52 plus 15, plus 21,
plus 88 is 176.
51 plus 15, plus 88,
plus 22, is 176.
So whichever way you go,
diagonal, across, down, check
it out for yourself,
it adds up to 176.
Well, let me show you what's
different about the way I've
drawn this.
If I now turn it upside down.
I have 11 plus 22,
plus 58, plus 85,
which is equal to 176.
82 plus 51, plus 25,
plus 18 is 176.
And you go through--
28 plus 15, plus 81, plus 52--
is that 52?
I can't write.
Yes, that's 52.
That's 176.
So whether you read it upside
down or backwards,
it's still the same.
But there's even
one more thing.
One more thing, which is
absolutely beautiful.
I can now get a mirror and
place it next to it.
And you will be able
to see the top row
reads 28, 82, 55, 11.
And the next row is 15,
51, 88, and 22.
These also add up to 176.
So this is not only a magic
square which I can turn upside
down, I can also look at
it reversed in a mirror
and it's still 176.
So this is why this is more
than just a magic square.
It is a magic square
in different ways--
reversing, and mirror imaging.
And I find that incredible.
It wouldn't have existed, of
course, before we had these
modern ways of writing twos
and eights and fives.
Of course, you can't do
it that way 'round.
That doesn't work.
That doesn't make any
sense at all.
So it's only up and down.